hey everyone Ashley crawls in here with  extremely exciting Star Wars news the  long-standing rumors are true Donald  Glover is officially joining the Star  Wars universe as young Lando Calrissian  this to you is getting worse all the  time or as director Chris Miller tweeted  this deals getting better all the time  lover is joining the standalone han solo  movie directed by duo Phil Lord and  Chris Miller coming out in 2018 conselho  himself will be played by alden  ehrenreich goolies officially announced  at Star Wars Celebration europe in july  and being in that audience i gotta say  in this casting along with Donald lovers  is pretty freaking perfect as a kid you  play make-believe and you imagine oh and  you kind of imagine what it would be  like it's pretty incredible so I'm just  the very very exciting  you